[Applause]
a stunning mandate prime minister
antonia costa's ruling socialists have
won a majority of seats in portugal's
snap election
it's a feat few could have imagined
coming into the election pre-election
polling had them nearly even with the
second place center-right social
democrats
the election was triggered when other
leftist parties voted with right-wing
parties to kill the 2022 budget
that put costa's rule at risk until he
pulled off sunday's victory
the socialist will have the votes now to
pass the budget
it was a victory of humility of
confidence and for stability firstly i
want to say thank you to all the
portuguese for the exemplar way the
electoral campaign took place for the
civic way that these elections took
place in such a difficult moment for all
of us his main rival rui rio the leader
of the center-right social democrats
acknowledging defeat and implying he may
step down as party leader
with the socialist party's governing
period of four years i sincerely don't
see how i can be useful in this
framework the party will decide but i
sincerely don't see how i can be useful
in this context for four more years
the far right wing party sega or enough
also celebrating they received the third
highest number of votes the first such
showing for a far right wing party since
the arrival of democracy in 1974
a sign of the attraction populism holds
after two years of pandemic pain one of
the problems that we have and this might
explain a little bit why this right-wing
party
is rising is that portugal is not
growing uh
as the other countries in the european
union it's getting uh backwards now it's
the seventh poorest country in the 27th
of the european union donning protective
gear poll workers even received coveted
positive voters who left isolation to
cast their ballots and what many saw as
the most important election in decades
the election was defined by the pandemic
with voters calling on parliament to get
the economy going again and to
effectively manage the handling of
billions of dollars from the eu recovery
and resilience fund
adam rainey al jazeera lisbon